[Music]
foreign
welcome back so today we are continuing
this lecture on numerical integration of
Odes
specifically we're trying to predict a
trajectory of a non-linear system x dot
equals f of x and when I say A
trajectory I literally mean
um you know I want to know kind of where
X goes in time so if I have some initial
condition X naught I want to be able to
step this forward at discrete Delta T's
in time so I want to be able to get you
know exit time step one exit time step
two
X at time step three dot dot dot all the
way up to you know some nth time step
these are vector States so each of these
X's might be a whole set you know it's
it's the minimal Vector describing my
system so for example later I'm actually
going to code this up we're going to
look at the um
we're going to look at the mass on a
spring with a damper and the minimal
state to describe this system would be
you know X this Vector State equals its
position and its velocity
so I hope you're okay at this point this
has been many many lectures where you
know we write down our Vector state with
an underbar and that's the vector of
positions uh the the vector of states
needed to minimally describe our system
and in this case for f equals m a
physics systems the position and its
first derivative the velocity is kind of
a minimal State needed to describe that
system as a first order system of
differential equations so that's what I
mean by this these are all kind of
vector States uh evolving in time and so
specifically when I say subscript here
that means at the third time step or at
the second time step or at the first
time step
so X at the kth time step is X at time
TK where TK is being sampled uniformly
in time at delta T intervals so imagine
you have kind of a you know some
metronome measuring every delta T and so
the TK the kth time instant is just K
times some delta T and generally we're
going to choose delta T to be a small
time step used to sample our system and
to numerically step our system forward
so the name of the game here is to build
a numerical scheme this numerical
integrator that will approximate the
system uh how to move the system forward
in time so specifically if I have
you know X at time K how do I step that
forward to X at time K plus one there's
going to be some big function f that
we're going to derive today that if I
have exit time K it'll map my forward
map my system forward to the next time
step K plus one okay and if I have that
function f then I can start with my
initial condition X naught and I can map
that to X1 with F I can map that to X at
the next time step time step two with f
and I can keep doing that to build this
trajectory all the way up to some X at
time Step n
and so the way we're going to do that so
I'm going to start off really really
simple in this video what we're going to
do is we are going to start by deriving
the simplest numerical integrator the
simplest function f that sets our system
forward based on a finite difference
derivative approximation to x dot to DX
DT this is the forward and backward
Euler integration schemes so today I'm
going to be talking about Euler
integration
which is really the simplest the
simplest scheme possible and we are
going to code up an example and then in
the next lectures I'm going to tell you
how to analyze these numerical
integrators for their error properties
and stability properties
okay so let's get started the basic idea
here is that we're going to take our x
dot equals f of x and we are going to
replace this perfect analytical
derivative DX DT we're going to replace
DX DT with our approximation of the
derivative which is and this is
so if x is a function of time then DX DT
is also a function of time the
derivative of my state X is also a
function of time so really I've been a
little sloppy this is really x dot of
time equals f of x which is also a
function of time at some time instant T
the derivative of x with respect to T
equals F evaluated at my state at that
time instant t
and so I can write this as uh you know
DX of t
DT equals or it's approximately equal
to X at t plus delta T
minus X at T divided by delta T okay
that's a very valid approximation and we
saw earlier of course from Calculus if
we take the limit as delta T goes to
zero then this is exactly the derivative
x dot but numerically in a computer
we're not going to take this limit as
delta T goes to zero we're going to pick
a finite but small delta T
uh to approximate this derivative and
that of course because you know it
approximates x dot it also approximates
f of x so this also approximates f of x
at time step T okay and so now for any
time step for any time T now what I can
do is I can multiply both sides by delta
T and add X of T and I get this nice
expression
that X at time t plus delta T
equals x of T my current time
plus delta T times f
X of t
really really simple update rule that if
I have my state X at time now at time t
i can evaluate this and this and I can
get my state X at my next time step t
plus delta T and again these are all
Vector X's with under bars if I haven't
you know written them down please
forgive me sometimes I forget to make
sure these are all Vector X's my state
of my system they might be two
dimensional Vector they might be a
million-dimensional vector but X is you
know a state of my system
and this is an update rule so this is
literally this F I'm talking about this
is some big F of
X of t
and so in particular if I have X at t k
and I apply this function to it that
will give me X at time T K plus 1. okay
so let's just you know I think this is
pretty easy to verify that this is true
X at time T K plus 1 is X at
um
K plus 1 delta T so that's K plus 1
delta T
which of course equals x at
K delta T
plus delta T
okay that's just expanding this time
here which equals x at this is t k
plus delta T
okay I'm just showing you kind of how
you can very very naturally go from an
index you know T K plus 1 literally
means K plus 1 Delta T's which is the
same as T K plus 1 delta T that's these
are equivalent okay that's all the stuff
on the left and that equals that equals
my big F function this function here
evaluated at time t t k so that equals x
at time t k
plus delta T
f of x
at time t k
okay good so what I've shown you is that
exit time T K plus 1 is this f of x at
time t k that is literally like if I
have X at time now I can step that
forward to one delta T in the future and
so this is kind of the scheme I could
also write this with subscript I could
say x k Plus 1. because that's exit time
T K plus 1 equals x at time k
plus Delta t f of x at time K and this
is usually the form I'm actually going
to to write it so so I went through all
of this kind of indexing and I hope I
didn't lose anyone but I I did that
specifically to show you that this
finite difference derivative where I you
know I was thinking of X as a continuous
function of time
we can then if we pick discrete time
updates discrete delta T time steps we
can go through all of this math and
write this down using this index
notation and the way I read this I like
to say this in words x at time step K
plus 1
equals or it's approximately equal to
exit my current time step TK plus a
little delta T times my function f
evaluated at X at my current time step k
so every time you see x sub K that means
X evaluated at T sub K my kth time step
which is K delta T okay good so that's
the notation we're going to use for all
of these lectures
and this is my forward Euler scheme so
this is
um
this is forward Euler forward
Euler and we'll find out that this is an
okay approximation scheme for my my
um my trajectory but it's not very good
it's like the simplest simplest simplest
thing you can do just like this is not a
very good approximation of the
derivative there's way better
approximations of the derivative this is
kind of you know the first quickest
dirtiest numerical integrator you could
write down is forward Euler but it works
in a pinch and it's really easy to
analyze so that's where we're going to
start
okay good
um what else do I want to show you so
I'm going to show you how to do
something called backward Oiler and then
we're going to code this up on the
spring Mass system and we're going to
analyze a little bit of what these mean
maybe I'll give you a picture real quick
of how to interpret this so again let's
say I have some Vector field like the
Gulf of Mexico Vector field from before
okay so this is some Vector field where
my particle X is is lives inside the
Specter field and it's moving around and
x dot equals f of x let's for now assume
that this Vector field doesn't change so
it's a really still day and it's not
changing it's just kind of a constant
flow of velocity
uh and what we're trying to do is we are
trying to take you know we have let's
say x at time step k
and we're trying to step it forward to
exit time step K plus one okay and so
what we do with forward Euler this is a
really really simple interpretation of
forward Euler the way that you integrate
forward in time
is you you query your system you say
what is my Vector field what does my
Vector look like at my current location
exit time step K so X now
maybe I have a vector that looks like
this okay that is like DX DT that's my
my DX DT Vector how much X changes in t
and since we're time stepping delta T
forward in time I want to know how much
my system goes forward in time I
literally take that vector v
times a little delta T and I add it to
my current
XK that's kind of you know morally
what's happening here as I take this
vector
which is f of x at time K I multiply it
by a little delta T because I'm taking a
delta T time step and this is you know
my derivative of x with respect to time
and this is how much time I'm going so I
take a little you know
V times delta T step and that gives me x
k plus 1. it's that simple forward Euler
is that simple you you know at my
current time step it's my current time
step plus this little delta T times my
velocity step and that's x k plus 1. and
then at x k plus 1 I query my Vector
field and maybe now at x k plus 1 it's
pointing in this direction and so now I
take a little delta T step in that
direction to get x k Plus 2. and now
maybe at x k plus 2 my Vector is
pointing in this direction and so I take
a little delta T step in that direction
and that gives me x k plus 3. and so you
can see it's almost this little
piecewise linear approximation and I'll
show you in a minute it's based on a
kind of first order Taylor series
approximation of this derivative okay as
as you might expect because this is a
first forward difference derivative I'm
only using kind of the first term of the
Taylor series approximation
um to get this I'll come back to that in
the error analysis but this is a picture
that shows you kind of morally what this
forward Euler scheme is doing okay so
um maybe what I'm going to do is I'm
going to erase this rewrite this down
and then I'm going to show you what
backward Euler is so just one second
Okay so
just everything and I rewrote my forward
Oiler here and I changed my notation a
little just you know I want you to get
really comfortable with the subscript
notation because this is how all
numerical schemes are written is I
approximated my derivative x dot at time
step t k times TK
as X at time K plus 1 minus X at time K
divided by delta T and of course that
equals you know since it's x dot at time
t k that equals f of x at time K okay
and so if this is a little confusing
pause the video write this down and
convince yourself that this is exactly
what I wrote down before I erase the
board and that derived this forward
Euler scheme that we wrote here
and then uh similarly backward Oiler
essentially uses this exact same
derivative except now I'm using this is
a forward difference approximation of x
dot now we're going to do a backwards
difference approximation of x dot so I'm
actually going to write it the same way
I'm going to write it as so this is
backward Euler
uh backward Euler
and backward Euler I'm going to write it
the same way where I have x k plus 1
minus x k divided by delta T
this is the backwards difference
approximation of my derivative this is
approximately equal to my derivative x
dot at K plus 1 at time step t k Plus 1.
so this at time k
I would use K plus 1 minus k for my back
for my I'm sorry forward difference so
at time step TK I would use T K plus 1
minus TK for my forward difference
because this is a point that is one
delta T forward of this one and that
same scheme could be the backwards
difference approximation at T K plus one
okay so the derivative of x
um and I could write this out as you
know it's literally exit
um
t plus delta T minus X at
T this is t k t k
divided by delta T that is approximately
the derivative you know d x d t
evaluated at time T K plus one okay so
this is and at time T K plus one if I do
this minus TK that's a backwards
difference derivative so uh that's why
we call it backward Euler because it's
based on this backwards derivative and
so notice here the only thing that
changed was x dot is now a function of T
K plus 1 on the right which means this
is approximately equal to f of x k Plus
1.
and so that similarly implies
that we can now you know multiply both
sides by delta T and add XK and I get x
k plus 1 equals x k
plus Delta t f of x k Plus 1.
this is my backward Euler scheme okay
I'm going to circle this one just so you
remember this is my forward Euler scheme
uh and there's something kind of a
little weird happening here that now
remember I want to be stepping my system
forward in time I want to be able to
predict pre predict my trajectory X at
time K plus 1 just from the information
at Exit time K the current point in my
trajectory and here this makes sense
this is called an explicit scheme this
is explicit
because x k plus 1 is an explicit
expression of x k so all I have to do is
plug in my data now at time k at the
current time that I have and I get my
time step my next time step information
this is called implicit sometimes it's
also called implicit Euler
implicit
Euler because now the thing I'm trying
to solve for x k plus 1 exit my next
time step is on both sides of this
equation so it's kind of an implicit
function this is an implicit
function
of x k plus 1. and especially if f is a
non-linear function I have to do some
weird thing to invert this F to solve
for x k plus 1. it might be very
numerically complicated to solve for x k
plus 1. and so what we're going to find
in the next lecture is that
backward Euler actually has way better
stability properties it gives much more
faithful stable predictions of the
Dynamics
specifically because of this implicit
nature here but it's much much much
harder to solve for than forward Euler
so just the fact that I can kind of
build this map F this explicit map F
that takes exit time K and spits out
exit time K plus one that makes this way
way easier to code up and to solve this
one because it's implicit because
solving for x k plus 1 means I have to
invert this function which might be very
very nasty this is very hard to solve
but it's going to have better error
properties and better stability
properties so we'll come up with that in
a little bit what I do want to point out
is
um the way that we're going to analyze
stability and error for these two
integrators is we're going to look at
the idealized case that we had linear
Dynamics so if
um
x dot equals ax if my Dynamics f of x
were just linear equals ax then this
would become
then this would become x k plus 1 equals
x k plus delta T times an a matrix times
x k and I could write this as
the identity Matrix
plus you know delta T times my a matrix
times x k and so you know what we're
going to do is we're going to look at
this idealized case of linear Dynamics
and we're going to analyze the error and
stability properties of this
operator here and see how close is this
to the true kind of flow operator that
flows my system forward in time and
that's how we're going to understand
these things so here similarly
you know if
uh if x dot equals a x then again I
would have x k plus 1 equals x k plus
delta T
how do I want to write this delta T
a
a delta T x k plus 1 a delta T times x k
plus 1. and now what I could do is I
could actually move this over and I
could write this as identity minus
delta T A times x k plus 1 equals x k
and I can solve so if this was linear
Dynamics I can solve this implicit
equation by just dividing this Matrix
over and I get x k plus 1 equals
identity minus delta T A inverse times x
k so this would be again I'm going to
look at the stability properties and
error properties of this approximation
for implicit Euler and this
approximation for explicit Euler
assuming linear Dynamics that's how
we're going to do error analysis and
stability analysis for these two schemes
and I want to point out actually this is
super interesting if you look at
identity plus delta T A
these are the first two terms in the
Taylor series so these are the first
two terms
in the Taylor series
for you guessed it
of uh X of T equals e to the Matrix a t
times x naught so this Matrix
exponential e to the a t these are the
first two terms in the Taylor series
actually
specifically of
um
a e to the a delta T X
K plus 1 equals e to the a delta T times
x k the exact solution here this is the
first two terms in the Taylor series of
e to the a delta T so you can see
already that this is going to be you
know A first order Taylor series
approximation I can make this error
smaller by making delta T smaller but I
might be able to do better by including
more terms in my Taylor series similarly
this is the first leading Taylor series
of
um
well a more complicated implicit version
version of this okay
um good so we we know now how to derive
these we're going to use finite
difference derivatives we're going to
get these Expressions that work for
generic non-linear functions F but we're
going to analyze their error and
stability by assuming linear Dynamics
and then comparing with our exact
solution that we know the answer to
we're going to compare these expressions
and see if they're stable what the error
is
um
good maybe what I'll do right now is
um I think I'm going to stop here and in
the next lecture what I'm going to do is
I'm actually going to code this up both
of these schemes for this spring Mass
damper system so I'm going to stop here
and in the next lecture I'm going to
derive these equations of motion and
we're going to try these integrators all
right stay tuned thank you
[Music]
foreign